-Welcome, Paul. Welcome, Will!
Welcome to the show.
Happy Thanksgiving.
-Happy Thanksgiving. Yeah.
-Happy Thanksgiving.
-Happy Thanksgiving, everyone.
--Happy Thanksgiving, everyone.
Besides celebrating
here with us,
how will you be celebrating
Thanksgiving?
Do you have any traditions?
-Um, turkey.
-You do turkey?
-You go to Turkey?
-Cook a turkey. I do.
We cook a regular turkey
and then I do what's called
a Halloween turkey.
-I get it.
-And, I don't know if you do.
-I got it. No. No, sir.
-What I do is I collect all of
my kids' Halloween candy
I save it from Halloween,
and that becomes the stuffing.
-That's the stuffing right
there, absolutely.
-Whoa.
-So it's just a chocolate-y
nougat-y mess with all the
wrappers
inside the cavity of the turkey.
-That sounds delicious.
-I've heard of that, yeah
I saw Martha Stewart
maybe, do something like that.
-She did. She did.
-Yeah, that's right, I remember.
Paul, you are into, did you do
this for your turkeys,
do you air fry your turkeys?
-He does.
-I do.
-You're an air fryer?
-Yeah, yeah.
-He bought me an air fryer, too.
-Yeah.
-Can you explain the air fryer?
Because I own one.
-Uh, yeah they're great.
-Do you not use yours?
-No.
-Oh.
-Really? Oh, they're --
-I don't understand --
I used it once.
And then I go, I don't
understand what I did here
that I could've done in my
toaster oven.
-It's so easy to do.
-Yep.
-You oil the drum.
[ Laughter ]
No, I don't. What am I saying?
It's an oil-less fryer.
You don't oil the drum.
-Yeah, yeah.
You don't have to oil them.
Yeah.
-Oh, my God.
I almost, I almost --
-But you can, you can brine.
You can brine or not brine
your bird.
-How big is your air fryer
or turkey?
-Are you holding it?
-This is my air fryer.
Well, I have to hold the back of
it to yank the thing out of it.
-Well they have --
-Like a giant coffee filter.
-They got a different size drum.
You could stuff it with a
14-16 pound bird.
-Alright. And how -- yeah.
-And it comes with a basket.
And you put the bird
in the basket.
-Yeah.
-You drop it in,
you hook up to a propane tank.
It's got a hose, and you just
set your timer for 3 hours.
-Paul got me my own air fryer.
I was so excited.
And I took it to the propane
guy, like can you help me get it
and he was like, "That's just a
metal trash can."
[ Laughter ]
-Paul, you actually got Will a
metal trash can?
-I, uh, I was talking about,
I was talking about it.
I was talking big game.
And so I sent Will --
-A big game?
-A big game. I was talking about
I sent Will a air fryer.
It's great.
-You -- Really?
-I really love it.
-Because I made, like,
I think I reheat --
-Next year. Next year.
Since it's Thanksgiving tonight.
[ Laughter ]
You can use your --
-That's right.
-You can use your air fryer.
-Happy Thanksgiving.
-By the way Happy Thanksgiving.
-By the way --
-Yeah.
-By the way Happy Thanksgiving.
-I love that all these people
sacrificed their Thanksgiving.
[ Laughter ]
To be here.
-Okay.
-So great. So great.
-They all came right from the
parade, they're all --
-Oh, yes.
-They're all balloon operators.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's what we do --
-You guys do it every year.
-Every year.
-On the -- That's nice.
-Yeah, it is a nice thing.
-They work hard, it's windy.
And it's a lot of work.
-They're not recognized.
-We're floating.
This is a float.
[ Laughter ]
-This is the newest
Thanksgiving Day float,
"The Tonight Show" float.
And you guys are the guests.
And we're it, like,
another four hours,
so hey Happy Thanksgiving,
I'm glad you're here.
-Yeah.
-Cheers.
-There.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God you did it!
-His was edible.
-How did you do?
[ Laughter ]
Paul, how did you do that?
Paul, don't, here --
sorry about that.
I don't know that -- No, no,
Will! No! That's poisonous.
-Are these poisonous?
-No, that's really is.
They are poisonous, Will.
[ Laughter ]
-They probably are poisonous.
-There's something, there's
something wrong with this apple.
-Uh, thank you,
that's not an apple.
Welcome. I-I will say, Will, I
expected you a couple weeks ago
on our show and, uh, well,
you didn't show, to be honest.
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yea.
No. I never got the word.
My secretary never told me.
-[ Laughs ]
Franz?
-No, Little Wayne.
-Oh, man. Not the rapper?
-Not the rapper.
He's a 320 pound guy, we call
him Little Wayne.
-I get it.
-As like a joke.
-Yeah, it's funny. Yeah.
-His real, his name's Wayne.
-Yeah.
-Call him Little Wayne.
-Yeah. He's actually big.
-No, Little Wayne never
gave me the -- I feel --
and that's why we're here.
I feel mortified.
-Thank you for both sacrificing
and being here, because yeah,
you weren't here, Ryan Reynolds
actually stepped in to do the
interview.
-So nice of him. So nice of him.
-He's a good dude.
Some would say Ryan Reynolds is
a sexy man.
-Yeah! Oh, I know you're --
-But I would say --
-Yep, I agree.
-That he is not --
-Yes.
-The sexiest man alive!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Boom!
♪♪
-Ah! Whoa!
Oh, oh, oh!
Wow!
Boom!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whew!
-Because you are --
-You are, Paul, I think you're,
honestly --
-Oh, don't believe
everything you read.
-Ah.
[ Laughter ]
-I will say this, when we
announced it on our show --
-Yeah, go ahead.
-The audience went nuts
because everyone loves
Paul Rudd.
-I know.
[ Cheering ]
-Great guy.
-Including us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love you.
-thank you.
-And, I'm totally cool with it
because I turned it down.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, this is awkward.
-I called Paul. I go, "Paul,
I can't do it but something's
coming your way."
-I -- so I kind of Ryan Reynolds
in and took it over and got
the title, I showed up for Will.
-All you really good-looking
actors just do that for Will.
He bails on stuff --
-I bail,
I bail out all the time.
-That's what's -- we-- that's --
it's because we love him.
-Yeah.
-Well, yeah.
-I've never met him.
-Me?
-Yeah.
-That's right.
-It's a pleasure.
-You guys if -- You guys would
so like each other.
I can't believe it's been this
long that you've never even met.
-I would love it.
-I'm a big fan.
-I'd love to sit down and talk
with you sometime.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, when we come back we're
gonna sit down and talk
with Will Ferrell
and Paul Rudd.